[Applaus]
[Musik]
die diesjährige krone akademie und der
umgang mit ihr führte in einigen aber
nicht in allen staaten zu erneut
krisenhaften zuständen im
gesundheitswesen so gut wie überall
jedoch wurden im zuge der eindämmung
maßnahmen also loch dank schwere
wirtschaftliche schäden angerichtet die
folgen dieser wirtschaftlichen schäden
fallen zwar auch von land zu land
unterschiedlich aus aber was der uns in
erster linie vergegenwärtigen müssen ist
die tatsache dass sich hinter all den
zahlen diagrammen und statistiken wahre
menschliche tragödien verbergen
tragödien wie diese hier
[Musik]
nicht sagen schließt sein werk in
barcelona 3000 beschäftigte sind
betroffen
da haben also gerade 3000 menschen auf
einen schlag ihren arbeitsplatz verloren
allerdings sind diese 3000 nur der
allererste anfang sie sind sozusagen die
schneebälle die eine ganze lawine von
arbeitslosigkeit armut und elend
auslösen werden an einer autofabrik
hängen nämlich noch viele tausend
indirekte arbeitsplätze rund um den
islam fabrik gab es viele zulieferfirmen
die minister mit allem möglichen von
fahrzeugkomponenten über it leistungen
bis zu kantine essen versorgt haben
[Musik]
ihre dienste und produkte werden nun
alle nicht mehr benötigt und auch sie
sind nur die erste schicht an
zulieferfirmen denn an ihnen hängen
weitere sogenannte seconds tiefer flyer
und an denen wiederum weitere also ford
fiesta player insgesamt rechnen wir
damit dass in barcelona mittelfristig
allein durch diese eine werkschließung
mehr als 25.000 menschen ihre arbeit
verlieren werden wir sprechen von einer
wirklich dramatische situation denn dies
ist nicht die letzte autofabrik die
geschlossen wird und unzählige weitere
betriebe mit in den abgrund zieht doch
wahrscheinlich wird sich das alles
mittlerweile nicht sonderlich
überraschen schließlich verfolgst du die
entwicklung rund um die krone krise und
des bestens informiert so erwartest du
auch dass im laufe des jahres 2020 fast
alle länder in irgendeiner form einer
wirtschaftskrise erleben werden
[Musik]
der springende punkt jedoch ist nun die
frage ob wir es mit einer weiteren krise
wie wir sie schon öfter erlebt haben
oder er mit etwas das an eine zombie
apokalypse herankommen zu tun haben
eine zeitenwende einem epochalen umbruch
nach dem nichts mehr auf der welt so
sein wird wie zuvor noch bekommen die
menschen einzelner länder die
auswirkungen nämlich recht
unterschiedlich zu spüren in deutschland
zum beispiel ist die arbeitslosenquote
bisher gerade mal von fünf auf sechs
prozent gestiegen
in tschechien bisher sogar nur von 3 auf
dreieinhalb prozent heißt das dass sich
diese länder nicht in der krise befinden
doch aber ihre auswirkungen werden
zurzeit noch durch maßnahmen die
kurzarbeit stark abgefedert
beziehungsweise verzögert rechnet man
die kurzarbeiter hinzu kämen wohl bei
knapp 20 prozent raus aber es gibt
wirtschaftsbereiche und vor allem
anderer länder in denen wir von einer
echten krise im ausmaß einer zombie
apokalypse sprechen können diese länder
und ihre wirtschaft sind die walking
dead or alive und eines dieser länder
ist sparen
brüssel erwartet einen rückgang des bip
um 9,4 und ein anstieg der
arbeitslosigkeit auf 18 9 in spanien im
jahr 2020 ganz genau
alles deutet darauf hin dass spanien und
italien von dieser krise hart getroffen
sind
einerseits kam es dort zu einem
zumindest regionalen kollaps der
gesundheitssysteme welcher zu einer
schweren schock starre so gut wie aller
wirtschaftlichen aktivität im ganzen
land führte aber die ursachen haben wir
bereits in einem anderen video
besprochen ihr könnt es euch über den
link oben oder in der beschreibung
ansehen aber das ist nicht das
schlimmste
sowohl spanien als auch italien spüren
noch immer die auswirkungen der
finanzkrise von 2008 eine krise von der
sie sich noch nicht erholt haben
[Musik]
damit du dir das mal vorstellen dann ist
auch 2009 10 betrug die
arbeitslosenquote in spanien noch immer
fast 15 prozent in einigen gebieten lag
sie sogar über 20 prozent es gibt eine
ganze generation von spanien die weder
studieren noch arbeiten dem spanischen -
genannt werden navarra usd an
wir sprechen von menschen die 30 jahre
alt sind und noch bei ihren eltern leben
weil sie keine feste arbeit gefunden
haben und nicht über genügend einkommen
verfügen um sich eine eigene bleibe
leisten zu können
es handelt sich um eine ganze verlorene
generation das ist ein echtes nationales
drama wir sprechen hier über die
ausweglose situation und die tristen
aussichten vor der korona krise also zu
einer zeit als die wirtschaft in europa
noch prächtig wuchs
und jetzt stell dir vor weil ich in
zukunft diese menschen nun vor sich
haben natürlich werden jetzt ein paar
leute einwänden okay
seit ein paar monaten ist die wirtschaft
ins stocken geraten sie mussten alle zu
hause bleiben unternehmen haben ihre
produktion eingestellt aber das geht zu
ende und wenn wir alle wieder anfangen
zu arbeit zu gehen und zu konsumieren
sollte alles wieder normal laufen oder
nun ja in manchen fällen wirklich so
sein bestimmte sektoren können sich
recht schnell erholen ja sogar von der
krise profitieren sich quasi ein
größeres stück vom wohlstands kuchen
abschneiden das alles wird aber nichts
daran ändern dass dieser kuchen
insgesamt kleiner werden wird und ganz
viele werden nur noch ein paar kleine
krümel abbekommen die vorne und hinten
nicht reichen werden stell dir nur mal
eine bar in der nachbarschaft vor nennen
wir sie mal casa manolo serviert wird
dort tradition eine spanische küche
galizische hinten für schon ein bier
kostet zwei euro
das casino hat zwei angestellte magnolo
und eine köchin namens träumen
diese bar erwirtschaftet einen gewinn
von etwa 4000 euro pro monat gerade
genug für man nur um über die runden zu
kommen und kamenz gehalt zu bezahlen
zwei monate ohne einkommen können zur
schließung führen das bedeutet dass man
jolo die bar aufgepumpt kamen keine
arbeit findet der vermieter wird es
ebenfalls schwer haben einen neuen
mieter für die bar zu finden
vielleicht wird ihnen dies nicht
gelingen und er wird noch nicht mal geld
haben die räume für eine anderweitige
nutzung umzubauen
sie werden also verfallen und die
attraktivität und lebensqualität in der
ganzen straße nach unten sie nun es gibt
tausende solcher fälle spanien und
anderswo aber wir sprechen nicht nur von
bars es gibt auch große unternehmen die
nicht auf die quarantäne vorbereitet von
unternehmen wie dieses
jörg sagt dass corona virus habe die
einnahmen dezimiert und in den bankrott
geführt
all das ist ein globaler trend die frage
ist also warum hat spanien mehr probleme
als andere länder
welche zusätzlichen hürden die
deutschland oder die vereinigten staaten
nicht haben hat dieses land vor sich
welche zusätzlichen hürden die
deutschland und die vereinigten staaten
nicht haben hat spanien und was noch
wichtiger es gibt es überhaupt eine
chance diese hürden zu überwinden
heute werden wir diese fragen
beantworten und die immer fangen wir mit
einem blick in die geschichte an
[Musik]
der perfekte sturm in jeder krise gibt
es gewinner und verlierer unternehmen
wie amazon oder net wechselt aus der
krise enorm gestärkt hervorgegangen und
wer sind die größten opfer das ist nicht
schwer zu erraten die fluggesellschaft
dies wird der letzte sektor sein der
nach der quarantäne geöffnet wird und
viele gehen bereits pleite
[Musik]
avianca eine der größten
fluggesellschaften lateinamerikas meldet
konkurs an
welche sektoren sind also am besten
darauf vorbereitet die krise zu
überstehen abgesehen von
internetbasierten unternehmen wie sieht
es zum beispiel mit der industrie aus
dem gerade für den wohlstand deutschland
und ganz mitteleuropa so wichtigen
verarbeitenden gewerbe nun viele
betriebe haben sich auf die quarantäne
einstellen können im rahmen der
recherchen für dieses video haben wir
zum beispiel mit dem manager der
tschechischen niederlassung der
schwedischen firma atlas copco
gesprochen atlas copco ist ein typisches
mittelständisches multinationales
unternehmen das luft kompressoren vakuum
maschinen und andere maschinen für die
industrie herstellt hat das cocoon nutzt
wie viele andere industriebetriebe die
sommerferien um alle notwendigen
wartungsarbeiten durchzuführen sind
welche die fertigung angehalten werden
müssen die maschinen werden gereinigt
gecheckt variiert und modernisiert die
üblichen dinge eben nun in diesem jahr
hat atlas copco dieser arbeiten anstatt
bis zum sommer zu warten schon während
der ktl durchgeführt dasselbe spielte
sich bei vielen anderen unternehmen
nun ist alles wieder auf vordermann und
sobald die aufträge wieder eintrudeln
cannes auf hochtouren produziert werden
tja wenn aufträge wieder eintrudeln denn
dies hängt von den kunden ab diese aber
scheint ein bereich des industriesektors
ganz erheblich im stich zu lassen und
wir sprechen hier nicht von einem
kleinen akteur sondern von einem wahren
riesen dem motor der industrie ganz
mitteleuropas
die von corona virus betroffene
autoindustrie könnte noch stärker
betroffen sein als zuletzt
prognostiziert
beides war politik sagen wir schon seit
jahren voraus dass auf die großen
autohersteller gewaltige und immer
größere probleme zukommen werden ich
spreche hier von der deutschen
automobilindustrie welche fundamental
doch noch wissen sich so viele
aufgestellt ist als ihre konkurrenten
aus anderen europäischen ländern
doch wenn die deutschen schon derartige
probleme haben was passiert dann erst
mit den franzosen spanier und italiener
nur da kommt es bereits jetzt zum
blutbad damit du dir eine vorstellung
von derzeitigen impact machen kannst
bereits vor der krise setzte die
ratingagentur fitch die schuld anleihen
von renault auf board status und wenn
der renault konzern bereits damals in
einer schlechten verfassung war befindet
er sich nun am rande des bankrotts
[Musik]
die aktien des renault konzerns zu dem
auch nicht angehört wurden im jahr 2018
so einem kurs mit 98 euro pro stück
gehandelt
februar 2020 also kurz vor der krise
waren diese bereits auf rund 30 euro
gefallen und einen monat später lag der
kurs noch bei 10 euro
der aktienkurs spiegelt natürlich nur
die finanzielle misere inhalt des
konzerns wider
die unternehmensführung war gezwungen
sich hinzusetzen und drastische
entscheidungen zu treffen bisher wurde
angekündigt dass weltweit 15.000
menschen entlassen werden und die ersten
3000 hatten das pech in barcelona soll
[Musik]
während der korona virus krise schließen
ist an seiner fabrik in barcelona und
seine 3000 mitarbeiter sind arbeitslos
aber die wahrheit ist dass sie nicht die
einzigen sein werden nissan hat zwei
weitere werke in spanien eines in ávila
und eines in santander und renault hat
drei weitere werke war görlitz valencia
und sevilla
manche von euch wird es überraschen dass
spanien nach deutschland die zweitgrößte
operation europas ist aber gerade dies
macht es in der aktuellen situation umso
verwundbarer denn es ist ausgerechnet
von zweien der am stärksten von der
krise betroffenen sektor name vom
tourismus und neben der
automobilindustrie
der tourismus ist für 11 prozent des
spanischen bruttoinlandsprodukts
verantwortlich und die
automobilindustrie für 8,7 prozent
insgesamt sprechen wir von fast 20
prozent des spanischen ddp das heißt die
korona krise trifft ein ganzes fünftel
der spanischen wirtschaft mit voller
wucht
[Musik]
und was ist mit den übrigen vier fünftel
nun auch dort sieht es alles andere als
rosig aus kehren wir zu unserer beispiel
gemeinte kasan hanjo zurück eine
typische bar um die ecke mit einem oder
zwei angestellten eines von ganz vielen
kleines unternehmen welche die krise am
stärksten kraft und nun sieht der mann
das folgende diagramm in deutschland
sind 82 prozent der unternehmen kleines
unternehmen in spanien und italien
jedoch steigt diese zahl auf ganze 95
prozent
[Musik]
welche konsequenzen hat das nun wir
wissen dass deutschlands wirtschaft vor
allem dank ihrer vielen
wettbewerbsfähigen mittelständischen
unternehmen so stark ist es sind die so
genannten hidden champions zumeist
weltweit führend in ihren sehr
spezifischen nischen durch ihre hohe
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und meist
konservative finanzpolitik sind sie
meist solide kapitalisiert das heißt ich
habe genug ersparnis und puffer und man
schlechtes jahr zu überstehen ohne
gleich schließen zu müssen
eine kleines unternehmen wie kasan jolo
dürfte jedoch kaum so gut für eine krise
gerüstet sein
nur mal zum vergleich im schnitt hat ein
unternehmen in deutschland 7,6
mitarbeiter in spanien jedoch nur 3,9
diese zahl drückt aber nur ein teil der
misere aus denn in spanien gibt es auf
der einen seite sehr große unternehmen
und auf der anderen eben
kleinstunternehmen dazwischen aber kaum
mittelgroße und das bedeutet dass
spanien viel stärker von der
wirtschaftskrise betroffen ist weil ich
weiß dass viele von euch franken werden
in einer situation wie dieser springt ja
der staat als retter in die bresche
nun ja damit hat er recht ich denke
selbst die marke bereichen unter euch
werden mir zustimmen dass in zeiten wie
diesen die hilfe des staates notwendig
ist auch hier gibt es je nach staat
gravierende unterschiede und hören der
spanische staat befindet sich nicht
gerade auf seinem höhepunkt der infa so
denkt die eine lobby wird zu beginn
benutzt haben mit der zombie apokalypse
sei weit hergeholt erklären werde jetzt
wer die real world walking dead center
und dass diese so sicher über den süden
her fallen werden wie der winter über
den norden und auch wenn sich das jetzt
nach einem ganz schön mischmasch aus
serien referenzen anhört ist die bittere
realität
the walking dead ganz egal welcher
politischer coleur so gut wie jede
regierung der welt greift nun ihren
unternehmen unter die arme
insgesamt haben die europäischen ländern
bereits mehr als zwei billionen euro zur
rettung ihrer volkswirtschaften
ausgegeben und ja ich sagte billionen
eine 2 gefolgt von 12 0
fast die hälfte dieser zwei billionen
euro ist für deutschland bestimmt dass
du dich zum beispiel daran dass ich
erzählt habe viele fluggesellschaften
würden dicht machen nun deutschland
bereits alles was es kann
um dies zumindest bei der lufthansa zu
vermeiden
deutschland erreichte eu deal über 9,9
milliarden dollar lufthansa
rettungsaktion und er rückschlag musste
die eu um erlaubnis bitten weil das
europäische recht es regierung verbietet
ihren eigenen unternehmen aus der
patsche zu helfen denn das ist
eigentlich ein verstoß gegen den freien
wettbewerb in der union
wir haben es jedoch mit einer
außergewöhnlichen situation zu tun und
in einer zeit wie dieser lässt rüssel
dinge zu die zu jedem anderen zeitpunkt
völlig undenkbar gewesen wäre aber die
frage ist natürlich wer bezahlt das
alles hat der deutsche staat suchen geld
auf der hohen kante in der lage ist also
eine unternehmen zu halten nun die
wahrheit lautet nein
deutschland wird sich spanien frankreich
oder italien
dieses geld leihen müssen wir sprechen
von schild anleihen die auf den markt
ausgegeben werden und du sagst okay wo
liegt das problem warum kann sich
deutschland verschuldet und spanien
nicht nun hier kommt ein weiteres großes
problem spaniens zu vorschein
die deutsche staatsverschuldung beläuft
sich auf weniger als 60 prozent des
produkts produkts doch in spanien liegt
die zahl bereits jetzt über 95 prozent
und in italien sprechen wir von mehr als
134 prozent nun stell dir vor du bist
ein investor der in staatsanleihen macht
eigentlich bist du das direkt oder
indirekt sowieso schon
du stellst dir also die frage welche
staatsanleihen würde ich lieber kaufen
die deutschen oder die spanischen nun
bei den deutschen wissen will dass die
auswahl riesig wohl wesentlich geringer
ist als bei den spanischen tja und zu
welchem zeitpunkt schnell das risiko
eines ausfalls in die höhe
genau in extrem krisen wieder erzählen
und dies erklärt anmeldungen wie die
folgende corona wir uns die präsidentin
der eu kommission von der leyen sieht
mit dem 750 milliarden euro
rettungsfonds europas moment gekommen
haben schon vor ein paar wochen in einem
anderen video darüber gesprochen
niemand zweifelt daran dass europa
spanien oder italien hessen muss die
frage ist aber wie diese hilfe zustande
kommt die erste debatte drehte sich um
die korona box kurz gesagt die
nördlichen länder der eurozone wollten
den ländern des südens geld leihen unter
der bedingung einer politischen aufsicht
der es hören wollte das geld aber frei
von jeglichen bedingungen geschenkt
bekommen jetzt geht es in der debatte
darum ob die hilfe europas ist form von
darlehen oder subventionen erfolgen muss
schließlich hat die europäische
kommission einen mittelweg erreicht sind
100 milliarden euro an zuschüssen und
öffentlichen ausgaben 250 milliarden in
form von sehr zinsgünstigen darlehen
dieses geld wird aus
schuldverschreibungen stammen welche die
europäische union auf den
internationalen markt bringen es ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass viele diese
anleihen am ende sowieso von der
europäischen zentralbank aufgekauft und
damit bis in alle ewigkeit zitiert
werden aber die eigentliche frage lautet
dass es ausreichen und wird es
ausreichend einfach einen haufen geld
nach spanien zu schicken damit sich die
spanische wirtschaft erholt nun um das
beurteilen zu können werden wir doch mal
einen blick drauf was genau sich denn
dort abspielen
[Musik]
mehr excel und weniger powerpoint geld
ist wichtig aber noch wichtiger ist was
meinen wir damit nun ein paradebeispiel
dafür was den spannenden passieren viel
geld und wenig hirn zusammenkommen ist
der hochgeschwindigkeit 2 vl in den
letzten jahrzehnten hat europa mehr als
elf milliarden euro dafür ausgegeben
dass spanien und über
hochgeschwindigkeitsverbindung verfügt
auf den ersten blick handelt es sich um
eine erfolgsgeschichte
heute verfügen die spanier nach china
und japan über das drittgrößte
hochgeschwindigkeitsnetz der welt aber
die frage lautet was aufgebracht
eigentlich nicht viel aus
wirtschaftlicher sicht ist der
spanischen hochgeschwindigkeitszug avg
ein gigantisches schwarzes loch in der
volkswirtschaftlichen gesamtrechnung die
verbindungen haben kaum zu
wirtschaftlichem wachstum beigetragen
sie können nicht zur beförderung von
gütern sondern nur von passagieren und
aus sozialer sicht ist er schlicht und
einfach eine veranstaltung für reiche
eine zugfahrkarte in spanien ist
zwischen 40 und 100 prozent teurer als
eine vergleichbare verbindung in
deutschland oder tschechien aber der avg
ist erst der anfang
dasselbe gilt auch für die spanischen
geister flughäfen in spanien gibt es
flughäfen angeflogen werden aber ein
wahres vermögen gekostet haben wir
sprechen von milliarden von euro die aus
rein wahltaktischen politischen oder
sogar ideologischen gründen ausgegeben
wurden deswegen muss sich bei einem
gerade jetzt auf seinen hintern setzen
seine clique bunte powervollen
präsentation schließen und seine excel
auflagen
dort sollten die politiker endlich
anfangen genau durchzurechnen
welche investitionen dem land eine
besseres bescheren werden und weil hier
nicht und genau jetzt geht es mehr denn
je um sein stadt scheint denn all diese
unwirtschaftlichen projekte budgets und
unternehmen die künstlich am leben
erhalten werden ohne dass sie das land
voranbringen
das sind die zombiehorden welche die
restlichen lebenden immer mehr zu
ersticken drohen aber inwieweit ist
spanien bereits die ganzen politischen
eitelkeiten hinter sich zu lassen und
sich auf ein wahres
wirtschaftsmanagement zu konzentrieren
nun machen wir uns nichts vor
entlassung des chefs der guardia civil
löst politischen streit über
rechtsstaatlichkeit aus spaniens
regierung hat sich in einen streit
gestürzt in dem es um den vorwurf der
untergrabung der rechtsstaatlichkeit und
der untergrabung der demokratie sowie um
die konfrontation mit einer der
mächtigsten institutionen des landes
geht hinzu kommt die tatsache dass
spanien derzeit eine koalitionsregierung
hat eine koalition zwischen den
sozialisten mitte links und problemlos
einer partei der extremen leben und wenn
du dachtest linke parteien würden sich
immer verstehen dann hast du dich
gewaltig die spannungen zwischen den
gemäßigten flügel der tiere und dem
radikalen flügel wachsen zu sehen ist
und dass spannungen innerhalb der
regierung gesetzt was mir bereits
vorstellen was in den
oppositionsparteien los ist gesamte
politische umfeld ist hochgradig
polarisiert und das ist sehr
beunruhigend in spanien wird keine
andere wahl haben als seine ausgaben zu
senken und viele unpopuläre maßnahmen
umsetzen
viele dieser maßnahmen werden die
unterstützung der opposition benötigen
aber weißt du was urteile an dieser
stelle am besten selbst denn was du hier
sehen wirst ist eine szene aus dem
spanischen parlament für diejenigen die
mit der spanischen politik nicht
vertraut sind derjenige mit dem verein
schwanz ist der vize-präsidenten
regierung oder derjenige mit dem bart
ist ein mitglied der rechten partei
haustier an und sagen wir wie in diesem
umfeld einstimmige entscheidungen über
wesentliche maßnahmen erreicht werden
soll
[Musik]
damit wäre man schon alles gesagt oder
glaubst du dass europa die spanischen
politiker zu mehr verantwortung zwingen
kann ist es möglich dass europäische
hilfe dazu beiträgt die zombie
apokalypse doch noch zu verhindern und
so die krise erträglicher zu machen
bitte schreibt alles was euch dass du
ein feld in den kommentarbereich unter
diesem video
vergesst nicht dass wir jede woche neue
videos hochladen also verpasst keines
unserer updates abonniert unseren kanal
und legt auch auf das kringel symbol um
rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden
wir hoffen dass er dieses video etwas
gebracht hat als jahr gibt es auch einen
daumen hoch und unterstütze uns indem du
essen mit deinen freunden teils was gut
und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]